[Musique]
c'est bientôt noël ils sont nombreux à
s'empresser d'aller acheter leurs
derniers cadeaux et j'en fais partie il
me reste trois pour un budget de 50
euros on va voir ce qu'ils ont dû côté
de la galerie commerçante de saint
germain en laye on va commencer par une
librairie c'est parti
[Musique]
pour mon premier cadeau je crois je veux
partir sur une bande dessinée je connais
quelqu'un qui apprécierait plutôt sain
bonjour je vais prendre ça s'il vous
plaît donc comment ça se passe les fêtes
pour vous du monde c'est vraiment très
très bien les gens retournent à la
lecture en ce qui nous concerne en tout
cas et après les autres professions je
sais pas vraiment ce que consomme
vraiment c'est bien
[Musique]
tiens je vois qu'il ya une chocolaterie
là bas on va les voir pour notre
deuxième cadeau
bon deuxième cadeau j'ai un budget de 20
euros qu'est ce que vous me conseiller
pour un rouge et le coffret idéal pour
vous c'est un coffret et ganache ses
pralines et vous avez un bel assortiment
de chocolats pour arriver qu'est ce qui
marche bien en ce moment les gars l'âge
sur trois lignes on vous disait comme
dans le coffret les truffes les marrons
glacés superbe à écouter je vais partir
sur ce petit coffret du coa 20
euros/mois bien
[Musique]
il paraît que 77% des français sont
stressés à l'idée d'acheter des cadeaux
de noël on va aller voir si c'est le cas
ici dans la saint germain en laye
bonjour madame bonjour est ce que vous
êtes stressé vous à l'idée d'acheter des
cadeaux oui oui de devoir courir d'avoir
de trouver tant le monde les idées
le coup aussi moi je me régale j'adore
acheter des cadeaux de noël et je suis
pas du tout stressé suis un peu stressé
par les prix mais pas par le fait
d'acheter des cadeaux noël au contraire
c'est un grand moment de plaisir et de
joie nous on a anticipé les choses et
par conséquent on avait déjà les listes
bien avant les dates ultimes donc ce
n'était pas un problème du tout ni
stressant il me reste 14 0 61 seul
cadeau à acheter je crois que j'ai
repéré un petit marchand de bière
artisanale un peu plus loin dans la rue
on va voir ce qui peut nous proposer
[Musique]
pour mon dernier cadeau du coup qu'est
ce que vous me conseiller alors écoutez
ce que je peux vous conseiller c'est
consommer local là et pour ce faire j'ai
anti un petit pack découverte de bière
locale je peux vous proposez donc la
brasserie la petite soeur qui brassait à
sartrouville toussaint à louveciennes la
brasserie d'orville dans le 95 donc vous
aussi vous venez acheter votre dernier
cadeau de noël ici exactement je viens
chercher des petits coffrets pour mon
patron et mon collègue du coup moi je
suis partie sur les bières locales sur
quoi va s'orienter votre choix moi ça
allait plus je pense bière de savoie ou
issus des gaules
[Musique]
est ce plus tôt
les petits cadeaux car des derniers
ajustements tu vois c'est plutôt les
petits pour le dire bon beh peut-être
compléter ça fait plus de cadeaux à
ouvrir ça peut plus conviviale c'est bon
j'ai tous mes cadeaux à commencer donc
par la bande dessinée ensuite la boîte
de chocolats et on termine par le
coffret de trois bières locales pour
notre défi trois cadeaux pour 50 euros
c'est réussi passer de bonnes fêtes
[Musique]